all right hello friends
uh hopefully you can hear and see me
okay and i really wish i was there in
person unfortunately that didn't work
out but i'm happy to talk to you about
project tai today my name is john
galloway i'm a pm on the.net uh
community team
and so we'll just get right into it i've
got some slides at the beginning
to kind of describe what i'm talking
about but a lot of demos after that um
just if i may first of all who here has
used project tie at all
there if i could get a show of hands
anyone
nope okay cool
all right well so here's kind of my
general overview of what we're going to
talk about so
we'll kind of set the stage which is
generally what microservices are we'll
talk about how
project i can help and then tons of
demos and we'll see where it goes from
there
uh so first of all
what what do we mean by microservices
it's a bit of a definitely a buzzword
and so it's good to kind of step back
and look at that more
so you know in the course of my
programming career we've moved from
monolithic applications where we had one
big server or a few big servers running
really big apps everything was all kind
of in one big build and we've broken
that apart into microservices and
there's a few reasons there's it re
reasons and business reasons so the it
reasons are definitely you get a lot of
flexibility by breaking an application
apart into one big thing that you deploy
as one big unit
if instead you can break that down into
individual smaller components you've got
flexibility as you deploy them
one of the nice things about that
flexibility is then you can move
from uh
from hard you know from big iron servers
to virtual machines and then you can
actually go from there further to
containerized applications
so with a vm
you're getting some benefit to
abstracting from the hardware but you're
still kind of you're still running the
whole operating system and you're only
really virtualizing the machine
what if we could break that down further
and virtualize at the application level
so uh when we do that
we're
we're virtualizing away the operating
system and now we're down to just
scaling out by
by our units by our application as a
unit
and of course with that and running on
docker is kind of the most common
although there are some others out there
we get a lot of flexibility over what we
can do so for instance
if we're running with multiple
uh multiple instances on one machine and
it's underutilized we can swap them
around and
you know d uh shut down one of the vms
etc so that's all great from a hardware
perspective but
that's not really the only reason why
microservices are being used and
you know what i've been learning over
time is really one of the main impacts
is the business agility and what that
means is instead of waiting for one big
build when everything's ready to go we
can ship a service as soon as it's ready
and that also means that you can get
your bug fixes and features out much
more quickly so you can you know be
deploying multiple times a day instead
of waiting to make sure everything's
tested and works together
you can
also break things down at the team level
so you can
you can make some smarter decisions with
that one team might prefer to work with
you know net sql server etc another may
want to use you know f sharp and
postgres and another or a document
database or go or whatever right
so if you're if you're working at the
application level that it lets each team
and project decide what's best for them
and you can also focus on business
capabilities for a team so for instance
a team or a service may be completely
focused on ordering and they can really
become experts in that area
and so
you know brendan burns co-founder of
kubernetes has sum this up well that
it's microservices are really about
scaling at the team level
so uh
just a sec i'm going to adjust my
webcam down slightly there okay so i'm
not off the okay so uh what's nice about
scaling at the team level better is you
can work kind of at a micro team so you
think of it as a
you know working at
the size that can go out to lunch
together could eat a pizza pizza
together as opposed to 100 people on a
team or 50 people on a team and then you
can also by doing that
each person on the team can really
understand what they're building they
can understand the code and the product
and business as well
and then that forces you also to plan
for scale so
both your software but also your team
when you've got a small team then you
actually plan for
hey this new person on the team can
actually take over this you know our
data integration part or or our logging
or maintenance etc
so and that really gets down to
empowering individuals or teams quite a
bit more so instead of being one person
a huge team you're uh you are you know
really contributing
directly into a smaller team
okay that's all great hopefully i've
sold you on microservices they're
wonderful
so why isn't everyone using
microservices and especially in the
dot-net world
and i think
the main reason is that it's actually
pretty hard
there's a lot of complexity that you get
into
so
you know one thing is there's a lot of
new things to learn there's
there's a instead of just shipping to a
server there's all kinds of new software
and integration and different
technologies to learn
you also have a lot of decisions that
you've got to make
so you've got to decide which things and
how you'll integrate them etc and then
there's a ton of yaml code
so get ready to programming in yaml
so for instance uh you know that
well i've personally you know worked
with some some microservices i've worked
with teams that are working on
microservices as microsoft customers and
then also the the.net
uh team especially on the asp.net
tooling side looked into you know like
hey how can we make the best experience
and let's become better experts on
microservices so what are the things you
dig into well first of all of course
there's docker
and then uh you know if you're writing a
little bit of yaml you've got to write
your docker files to
you know orchestrate your docker
but then after that
in the real world people are deploying
mostly with kubernetes and there's good
reasons for that
it's uh you know it handles a lot of
things like um
you know fail-over and monitoring and
scale however
it brings a lot of complexity and so
there's a lot more to learn and along
the lines of the more you've got to
learn is the ammo because man oh man
there is a lot of yaml when you start
doing
uh kubernetes it just goes on and on
right so now you're a yamo programmer
and welcome to your new life
uh so then you say well i've got docker
files maybe i could use those to create
my kubernetes yaml
so so now you need to learn about
compose and then you've got to actually
run locally so now every time you change
a file you want to watch and restart
your services so now you're using
scaffold
and then you want to monitor your
application because
microservices applications can be tough
to understand what's going wrong and
what's making things run more slowly so
often people are using things like
zipkin and and then you need to debug
and understand more deeply
over time and so now you're doing more
logging and now so you're using
something like seek
so
because you're using all these different
things why don't we use a package
manager to orchestrate that so now
you're using helm and it's just a lot of
stuff to learn so
this whole thing of
okay you know let's move to
microservices
brings a lot of complexity and it makes
it a lot more difficult to start
number one learning as a developer and
number two
you know moving a new project into
microservices
so let's talk about project tai and what
it does there
so some of the main things that that
project thai is built to do is number
one simplify the getting started
experience you know really just
i want to start i want i've got an idea
for a small project or let's let's take
a look at how we can move a small
project into
microservices it definitely simplifies
that
it also simplifies the developer inner
loop as you are building and debugging
and you know adding new features on it's
a lot quicker when you're working with
project time
and then
the one thing that is not you know i
really kind of focused on it first was
oh project ty's going to help me deploy
my applications and that's not really
the main goal of project high
so
you know well project time will help you
it can can do things like uh help you
test your deployments it can help you
generate kubernetes yaml that's not
really the goal of what it's doing for
you
so
uh
so just a sec i'm checking one thing
here great okay so so
and i've gone through that there we go
all right so let's talk about what we
simplify
so
the team did a really smart thing i
think here
and
what they did was they said let's not
build
something instead of docker and
kubernetes and compose and scaffold and
all these things let's run on top of as
much as we can already right so let's uh
let's look at what we can understand we
can do things like you know parse
through
solution files we understand.net pretty
well we can parse you know we can use
like the docker cli and the kubernetes
cli and we can use them and orchestrate
them to
run on top of those things for you so
that's actually what it does and so i
really i think that's one of the key
takeaways here is that project tie is a
developer tool
and it does not it's not something you
use instead of docker or kubernetes or
these other things it's something that
you use with them to help you
build more quickly
so
uh as an example this is these are some
analogies that uh a friend of mine john
gallant at microsoft we have very
similar names and we get each other's
emails sometimes
but you know he said you know like look
you can get started with docker files or
you could use tie run
instead of you know going through and
writing
docker compose you can use a thai yaml
file which can uh you know which is very
simple and actually uh
they can parse docker compose files into
the ammo
you can debug and that's actually one of
the cool major features is the debugging
story and i'll be showing you that in a
second
and then
you can watch as you're building so you
can watch for changes and automatically
restart
and you can actually generate your
kubernetes when it's time to deploy
um and then you can well it's not the
the key use case you're not you're
probably not going to be deploying to
production using tie
you can test your deployments using that
so i'll show you that as well
all right that's most of my slides let's
get into some demos
so
what i'm going to do here is i'm going
to switch over here and i've got an
empty directory so it is there's nothing
going on there
so we will just create some stuff so
i'll say net
let's give it a
web app
we'll call this our front end
all right
and i'm starting with this in the
command line just to show at a very
simple level something that will work
everywhere of course you can do
this same thing in um in visual studio
right or whatever you choose
okay so we've got we've got a front end
now we'll also do net new
web api
we'll call that back end
so these are just two simple.net
projects we've got a web api and we've
got a web app front end all right now i
want to group these together so i'm
going to use a
solution so we'll say net
new solution
and it's going to by default give it the
name of our folder so this is hello tie
and then i'm going to um
now i could go through and create a
bunch of other things in the real world
and i'll be showing you samples in a
second
i would write code in these where
they'll talk to each other right so the
front end will have code that calls into
the vacuum
so i'm assuming you know
you know how we would do that and i'll
show you that more of that code in a
second so now let's run this with
project tai
so i have first of all gone and gotten
project tai and where i did that is
here's on the
uh the website so this is dotnet thai
and github
and um
or if you search for project high it's a
pretty distinctive name and then in the
getting started documents
it is a global tool so you do net
install dash g
this is if you want to install the
release one or you know the the latest
uh build at 0.10 whatever i am a glutton
for punishment so i'm using a um i'm
actually using
version
o11 dev which i built from source
yesterday right so that's that's
something you can do as well
and so i can just say tie
run
and when i do that
it is it knows oops
no services found in hello off to a
great start
um oh
i created a solution so
all right created a solution with no
projects in it so let's add our projects
to our solution
okay so dotnet solution add frontend
and
dotnet
okay
so now we have an actual uh solution
with two projects so let's try one more
time with feelings so dot uh tie
run
okay so now it is going out it's looking
at my solution it's saying oh i
understand.net you've got two projects
here you've got two you um so i'm going
to start those up for you it's also
created this dashboard which that's kind
of interesting so we're going to want to
check that out
so
it's launched all these things it says
it's waiting okay great so i clicked on
this
um i'm launching
there
so
when i clicked this and ran it it has
created a dashboard for me so already if
it did nothing other than this this is
saving me some time
this is nice because i've got my url
smart for my front end and back end i
can go in and i can understand
metrics of these running applications so
it's monitoring them for me so now let's
go into my front end
front end is just a you know web app
and the back end if i go here it's going
to give me
nothing because
uh
you know it's it's a web api but if i go
over here to swagger
all right there's my back end and i've
got my weather forecast and all that
and then um it's gonna do things like
handle you know logging and all that
sort of stuff for me so that is the kind
of basic hello world with tie
and that's already um
you know doing a good amount for me if
that's all it did but what's really nice
is that it's actually
setting me up to go a lot further with
microservices so let's dig back into
that in a second let's go here to my
slides so that is the tie run experience
so you can also
as a next step we can debug our
applications and
what's
what's going on here may seem simple but
it's actually really cool um
debugging into containerized
applications that are running in docker
is a little bit more complex you know
you're going actually kind of across
boundaries you're going into a container
you are attaching to that process it's a
little tricky
so what the team did here that's that i
think is pretty slick is they actually
delay
the process of dockerizing your.net
applications until the last minute so
here like if i bring up docker desktop
um let's go in here i've got some random
things that are running i don't know why
i'm running redis i should probably oh
no we can delete that
all right we'll remove that guy so
actually none of these are running right
now okay so if i go over into my
application it's running
and these things are ready these are
running
basically as kind of virtual containers
but they're not actually dockerized yet
so the advantage that gives me is that i
can actually go in and easily debug them
so i'm going to shut that down
and i'm going to switch over
and so i just did ctrl c to stop that
now i'm going to switch over to
some of the samples so this is in the
samples repo and i'm going to go to one
called front end back end see
so i'm going to show you two ways that
we can debug that um
let's see
okay so if we do uh code dot
pop this over into
yes code
now i'm going to give a caveat here
which is i'm playing with the latest
builds of everything and i found some
ways to break this tooling yesterday
it's probably all my fault and i will
take all the blame but
um i'm this one may fail and that's why
i've got some screenshots and recording
of it just in case so um
this one has a thai yaml file
you don't need to enamel but you can use
it so let's go back actually to this one
that we are looking at before
so there's my one that just had a
solution front end and a back end
okay
and
if
if i want to go in and start bringing in
other docker things maybe i want to
bring in a
postgres as a docker image or i want to
bring in some other monitoring or
something
or maybe i'm working with a team that
develops something and they deploy using
an angular front end as a docker image
so in that case i can say tie and knit
so when i do tie and knit it's it's
going to tell me
that
okay so now i'll say
um so there there is a simple thai yaml
file
so it just says here's what i found
here's the projects i discovered
um and here just a sec let's
yes i should have done that keep mistake
okay
so it says here are the you know the
projects i discovered and now you can go
ahead and add to those and i'll show you
adding to those in a second so i just
want to explain what that tie in it is
right there so now if i want to go and
run this i'm going to debug this from
inside the
the terminal inside of
of um
v visual studio i have vs code sorry
and i'm at an enormous
zoom
so i'm backing up just a tiny bit
okay so now i'll say tyrone
so this one is an example that has a
front end and back end that are set up
to work to talk together using a service
discovery i'll show you that in a bit
so i said tyrone it's going to do that
same thing again it's it's using this ty
yaml if it exists so it says great you
saved me some work you told me where to
find the front end and back end i don't
have to go and discover them
but now what's neat is it's got i've got
this vs code extension
if everything goes right
then it may not because this is the
thing i found out how to break recently
yeah so
if everything goes wrong it'll actually
discover
uh those things now i found how to break
this let's see if i go over into my
other working example in vs code that i
had open earlier
so here's one let's do a tie run
and so this this is a more complex
example that's using radius and a bunch
of other stuff
all right let's watch if it finds it if
not i'll show you
what the experience looks like
okay so what it's supposed to be doing
is it's supposed to be finding the
running applications
and
so it finds the running applications and
it actually lets me step into uh hit
breakpoints and debug into them and i
can do that directly in this cool visual
studio code extension
so let's go in here
loading it up it's being slow because
i'm sharing my desktop
there it is okay
so there i'm running the application
and then i switch over in that left side
you'll see i click on that tie extension
and it actually finds all the running
things
so here it's got three dot net
applications
and i've set a break point in the code
and when i hit attach it actually goes
directly into that and attaches to that
process
and i can debug that
so this is something where like when i
went just now i tested on my on my mac
and i installed the latest of everything
the latest tie the latest release of the
extension and everything worked exactly
like you're seeing on the screen
so then i can go through and i can step
and debug and do all that stuff so it's
actually
thai is orchestrating and running all
this stuff but it's uh this extension
makes it really easy to go and and debug
through that
so this is kind of a nice experience and
this is along the lines of
you know what they're they're hoping to
do more of with um this kind of
integrated tooling for uh connected
services here so
so that's that's what i
was hoping to have however
i also if i don't want to do that
through here
so let's you know say i vs code neat
example but i really am working all the
time in visual studio or writer or
whatever you can also do this thing here
so this is uh i've run the application
from command line i'm in
i go into visual studio and i say attach
to process
then i can just say you know worker.exe
and so it's found that app that uh
instance and then i can debug right into
it
okay
so again what i'm what i'm uh trying to
show here is that this simplifies the
debugging experience because it runs
these as standard.net processes that can
be attached to and debugged
and waits until kind of i'm ready to
deploy before it makes me worry about
you know all that kind of debugging into
a container business
so
all right so we've done all that kind of
stuff let's say great we're we're
excited about this um we're ready to go
and start generating
some
uh some you know some files there so um
here i've actually gone and done that
and i'm going to delete that one just
because i don't want to um
okay
so now we'll say ty generate
all right and in this example
i've got a few more things i've got
uh i've got a front end and a background
back end i've also got some docker
images
so i've kind of mentioned that but i
haven't talked about this in detail yet
the idea with the docker images is that
i can very easily integrate those in so
here i've got
a
net project
here i want to use postgres and all i
have to say is postgres and it knows how
to find that and i can set things like
you know the password the bindings
connection string all that sort of thing
and then uh here this results is just a
standard dotnet project again and i
think i've got redis in here too yeah i
do
so i just said use redis so these are
all uh these are all documented but
they're pretty straightforward as far as
how to add these sorts of things in and
i'll show you in a bit too as well
adding in you can add in things from a
github repo you can add in things from
you know standard docker reference you
can add it you can give a link to a
docker file that's on your machine et
cetera
so now i've i've been running this i'm
ready to generate that kubernetes file
and get ready to deploy so i'll say tie
generate
so
it's looking at tiaml it's kind of
understanding all the stuff that's there
it's doing a lot of thinking it's
actually building docker images
so that it would be ready to deploy them
and then it's going to generate out this
kubernetes file and part of the reason i
like to generate this kubernetes file is
to
feel good about how much i'm not having
to write myself because uh because
for this i mean it's got a few different
things but it's not a hugely complex
application and here's the kubernetes
for it so
so here's all the stuff that it's it's
generating for me
and then i can go through and i can use
this uh to deploy
uh and you know i can turn this over to
my devops team etc right so
so that is kind of a nice um
you know time saver and a kind of way i
can check and see how things are going
for me
so
now let's say i want to test my
deployment on my local machine
so i'm going to do a few things here one
is that i've got mini cube installed and
midi cube is pretty cool it's um
it's a nice way to test out kubernetes
deployment locally so let's zoom in a
bit so if i go bangy
so it's it's a command line tool it's
going to give me a bunch of different
options and things i can do so i'll say
mini cube
status it's going to say probably it's
not running
pack so i'll say mini keep start
has some happy little uh
emojis on the cli which is fun
so it's starting things up
so what it's doing here is it's actually
running against a local kind of
kubernetes instance that it's set up on
my local docker
so
what's cool with this is then i can go
through and i can do an interactive
deployment of my application
so we'll let that go
and actually watch it as it spins up and
does things over here here's some other
things by the way i should stop my
running application if i haven't yet
okay there's that
start it up wonderful
um so
let's look at who we want to deploy
let's go to this one
okay so we'll say tie
deploy
dash i
and before i do that let me bump up the
font size
so
the nice thing with this interactive
mode is it's going to ask me some
questions and one question is
uh where is your container registry so i
can use like azure container registry i
can use um
docker hub in my case i'm going to use
docker hub for that so i've already set
up a docker hub mechanic
and part of the reason for that is the
way that kubernetes deploys is it pulls
from a container registry
so here it goes through and it builds
out those docker images for me
and it's actually going to uh
push that out so it's it's pushing out
out my
so this is a docker image for my
local.net
backend that i built
and then it's it's pushing that that
actually takes not a long time but it
takes a little bit of time it's actually
pushing out a docker image that can be
you know 50 100 megabytes and so it goes
through and it does that while it's
doing that let's see so if i go to
let's see it's gonna bring up on my
other
browser i'm already logged in
docker.com
i think it's gonna show
so here's examples here's some previous
ones that i've deployed to test out
right
so
it's doing that it's pushing those out
still pushing if it takes much longer i
will skip ahead and we'll we'll just
kind of talk through um some other stuff
and come back to it because i don't want
to waste time it does take so this is
something where i kind of had to wrap my
head around it a little bit i'm doing a
local deployment to my local kubernetes
cluster however it's still pushing it up
to a container registry and so this is
uh
docker hub which is across the internet
so it actually still has to push that
out so we'll give that a little bit to
do its thing and then we'll come back to
so that's thai deployment and again this
is something where i probably wouldn't
use this to deploy to production but
it's nice to be able to test that
deployment locally and uh and kind of
see what it's doing
all right
so
now let's go on and look at some more
advanced fun thai stuff
and um so one of the things is service
discovery
so
i kind of waved my hands and talked
around it earlier but when you are
building connected you know
microservice applications the services
need to be able to talk to each other
and so one of the nice things with this
is is uh using service discovery oh
and by the way this uh this ended up
just finished deploying so now i could
actually this this is out on my
kubernetes cluster
so i could go out here and i can look at
this and it's it's gone out and deployed
all this stuff right
and then i could go through and and uh
test it and run against it and that sort
of thing i think
i don't know
i may want to run this let's let's see
oh that's the cli
i don't want to do that
i'm going to get in over my head pretty
quick if i start messing around too much
this is going to show like here it's
running against um and it's i would need
to go through and i would need to test
out my ingress and stuff to be able to
test against that so so
i finished my deployment
and now actually i want to i've i'm done
with this and i don't want to keep all
those things hanging around so i'm going
to do the one last step of the
deployment which is tie undeploy so i'll
go to time
that's a that's uh always an important
step especially if you're running in a
you know public cloud where you could be
spending some money so that's that's
gone through and it's deleted those
things all right so back to what i was
talking about with service discovery
so if we look at this front-end back-end
sample
this this has a front-end talking to a
back-end so the the front-end is reading
weather from a back end weather service
and so the way it's doing that is pretty
cool so
the back end
it's actually in the front end we go to
startup
so it is getting a
back end
from this
configuration.getservice uri
now if you're not used to that get
service uri that's because it's pulled
in
from this
microsoft.thai.extensions.configuration
so this is a nuget package i added in
and when i did that
it made it easy to read configuration
so this this configuration then
that's all i need to do i need i tell it
go get the back end i i haven't gone
through and said oh and here's where the
back end is or whatever i've just said
go get it
right so that's how it's able to
discover it
and in a more complex example let's go
over to this voting sample
so the voting samples when i i showed a
little bit ago and that has postgres and
has redis and it has
a front end where you place a a
boat and it also has uh you know back
end workers etc so let's go
take a look at that
so this is an example where there's
front end talking to backhand talking to
redis talking to all sorts of things so
let's look
at a simple case here i think this the
vote page
is again going to use this get
it's going to discover
so here it's discovering a redis
instance
so it says get connections during redis
and where
the only place where that's been defined
how it knows what this magic string
radius is is this in this ti yaml
because here
we've got name is radius right so if i
call this hello everybody then in
here i would write get connection string
hello everybody so
that's all it does is it knows how to
read these things
we'll talk about how the magic happens
it's actually pretty slick we'll look at
that in a second
so there's how it's getting redis
then another neat one is in the worker
and the worker goes through and it's
connecting to
postgres
so where is it getting that from and so
here again
configuration git connection string
postgres
and that that configuration
is also
read from this uh tie configuration
all right
so to see how that's actually working
i'm going to spin this up again so we'll
do tie
run
so the magic here is in uh
environment variables
so when it runs it actually is emitting
environment variables and what's nice
about environment variables they work
everywhere they're cross-platform
they're um they're kind of a standard
way for services to communicate
and
and um
they
are easily discoverable so now let's go
and let's bring up the
by going to
that is selected we'll go
we will bring up our dashboard
up and up
hopefully this doesn't kill things
i've got more than one redis instance
running on the default port so we'll see
how bad
okay
so now if i go into like this
this vote
um for some of these when it starts them
up i'll be able to see
uh
when it spins them up it actually writes
out a ton of environment variables and
i'm not sure i have an easy way to look
that up
well
so i guess i saw them flash by
previously
forgetting where we'll see them when we
look at logging in a bit
but the main point i want to
mention there is that it it writes them
all out and one place you can also see
them
is in your
um your kubernetes file you'll see a ton
of different environment variables
listed in here so all these like service
vote protocol service vote host all
those all these kind of all cap
with underscores those are all those
environment variables that it's writing
out
so what's neat with that is then you can
see in this case actually when it says
okay go get me the you know redis
connection string etc or the postgres
so here's exactly how that magic wire up
happened so
that's that
okay so service discovery this also
works with things like like a dapper
dapper is something that they've been
building more integration with lately
and so that's something again where it
can communicate and it can look those
things up using those environment
variables
here's a neat thing that i just kind of
want to mention is there and point you
out if you're interested so this is a
cool example
this is
here
in
and there's actually tons of stuff in
the docs in
there's both a hello world tutorial and
then there's also these recipes
so oops
github actions
so this this is a github action and you
can just set this up and what this will
do is
when you commit code to a repo it can
deploy it using tie out to
aks so
that is pretty slick and that's just
kind of a built-in thing that it can do
and these are these we're in the section
here where i'm just kind of showing
here's a bunch of neat stuff you can do
and i'll tell you where to find more
about it later this is more just so that
you're aware of it
okay extensions are super fun and these
are things that you can turn on very
easily
you can do these with any docker image
but there's a few that have extra wire
up already set up for you
so i'll show you where you can find that
list of things that are already set up
so if we go into
i actually i like digging through the
source code in here
and if i go into the extensions
there's this well-known extensions list
so so these are some that they've kind
of written
special kind of wire up stuff for you so
dapper elastic seek and zipkin
so um
let me
go over it let me see so if i i want to
set up both zipkin and seek
so i'm going to go into one of my
applications let's go to a slightly
simpler one that's
working right now
let's also shut off redis because i
don't want
draw these things shutting down
go through and stop some extra stuff
make sure
one of the things is i'm jumping around
between a bunch of different
environments and starting and stopping a
lot of things i get
several things all running and occupying
the same chord so that's something i
like to do and shut everything down so
i'm going to switch back over to the
slightly simpler front-end back end
and what i want to show in this is
adding in two extensions
so i'm going to do this
there's i'll be honest one that i
remember from i remember very easily and
then another i forget and so i go and
look at the docs and i'll show you where
i do that
so we'll do first we'll do um zipkin
and then we'll also do seek
and i've probably gotten this
wrong already
um so let's go and i'll show you where i
look these up in the docs
and fortunately these are in um
these recipes
so they show you how to do this
so i'm going to go into recipes
we'll go into
zipkin
and see so first of all logging with
seek to show you how to do that and this
here so i'm doing extensions name seek
and log path and you have to give it a
log path it needs to know where to write
those out to
so i'll go into that
yeah so it's already wrong there we go
so there's that and then the other one
that's pretty easy is name
zipkin
and i don't need to give it anything
there
so
all right so now let's do tyron
okay so zipkin does distributed tracing
and seek does structured logging
so
um there i could use any docker file and
i can do some additional wire up for it
but they've kind of enabled some of the
kind of standard ones that are pretty
popular
so what's nice with that now this is
getting set up and running
go over here
okay
so now
if everything goes right first let's go
into our front end
let's go to our back end
okay great
so now let's go into uh zipkin
all right
so i run three
so there it's showing here's some things
and i could go and i can dig into
um this so what would be great here is
if let's say i've got a complex
application it's got front end it's got
a back end but the back end also has
ordering and it has
shipping and it has products and all
that and something slow and i don't know
what so i can actually go and i can
figure that out
so this was literally
one line of code to say turn on zipkin
so that that's pretty cool and then if i
want to check out seek for structured
logging
do that too
so let's go over to seek
and then in c i've got this kind of
fancy dashboard so i can go and i can
say all right here's my application
different events um
and then i can also dig into stuff like
okay here's here's a request and i can
go through and find more information
about it and then i can also run some
more advanced queries against both of
these
so these are two really cool extensions
and again
part of the big meta point i want to
show here is that
yeah i could go read how to do all this
stuff like if you go out and you look up
seek they've got a website they tell you
everything about how to install seek and
how you know how to
configure it and everything or i could
write one line of code and just get
started with it right and as a net
developer or a just a web developer
that's like hey i just want to get
started with and i want to develop
microservice applications locally this
is saving me a ton of time
so and again all i did here to turn
those on was
use this extensions path
so that's cool
all right
so i can also use any docker image and i
did show a bit of that already when i
was showing how we set up like for
instance um in the voting sample
uh i'll just kind of point that out real
quick and then i'll also point at the
schema for that so if i go into here
so the voting sample
shows how we do that and we're pulling
in
redis and postgres and both of those you
know all we do is say red asretis um etc
so i can also um so for instance i you
know i just say the image is redis
and i played with this a while yesterday
just um you know
finding like hey here's a random because
i was looking at different dashboards i
was thinking is there something i like
better than um
than zipkin and
or seek and so i just started playing
with them and
like literally i can just give a
reference to any docker image out there
it's kind of fun too
and this is an experiment because i just
want to try and break things so let's go
into my
um
let's go to front end back end
and now i think
see what i'm doing on time
so i can also put a
reference to
the um
to a repo
so let's see how i could do that let's
go into
docs
and then schema
schema
so here if i say github
does not want to search for me
there we go
so i can say here repository
um
and here i'll probably screw this up but
we'll we'll see what it would be like so
i'll just say repository
okay so let's go here
it's
repository
i want to point it at this repository
over here
all right so this is a general idea and
this is just a
very simple
pizza web app that i created recently
right so now we'll say ty run
so what i'd expect it to do is either
say your tie is invalid or if i'm lucky
it'll say oh i discovered this
repository i'm going to clone this repo
i'm going to copy the files in and i'm
going to include it with your
application
oh okay
nested configuration must have the same
name and the tie animal all right so i
would need to play with this but the
general idea there is that i can go
through and i can create um
i could also point to a
uh repo and what's nice with this is i
can also
see
so noticing me
i'll play with that afterwards uh but
what's nice is i can just delete it and
i haven't broken my whole entire
application which is also nice right
so there uh health checks so health
checks is really cool and this is this
is a neat integration point um
so asp.net core has great support for
health checks built in and so what those
allow you to do is you can have a
liveliness or a readiness probe
and you can basically
your application can say
yes i'm up but i'm not ready to receive
traffic or yes i'm up and i'm ready to
receive traffic
and so i'll show you that real quick if
we go into
let's do
if it doesn't
okay
i need to get into samples
all right it's it's going really slowly
for me so i may
skip past that but the idea here is that
you can integrate
the idea here is that they've hooked two
things together so
liveliness is uh there's health checks
or something that are just kind of built
in
to asp.net core so i can say
uh here is a health check so this is
something that i kind of recommend doing
regardless if you're using thai or
you know microservices or anything is
just add in health checks into your
application so you can register these
checks
so there's two kinds of checks one is
i'm i'm
running
but i'm not ready to receive traffic and
two is i'm running and ready to receive
traffic and then what's nice with that
is you can tell
uh you can use these in your tie yaml
and you can say i
you know
here's how you can tell if i'm awake
and or here's how you can tell that i'm
ready to receive traffic and then what's
nice with that is that can integrate
directly in
with kubernetes
and it's monitoring and if it says oh
this application or this node is not
lively it can actually restart it for
you so that's that's a really cool like
integration
there all right
there's a vs code extension i showed you
earlier um and if you're using the
released versions of everything it it
works just fine it's just i've managed
to break my local one
and then docker compose
that's something people ask about
regularly and they actually have written
an action for that where it can
find docker-composed files and parse
them out so if you create an application
using you know like i created a solution
and i had a docker compose file it'll go
and just find that for me
i had one other neat little demo that i
wanted to show real quick
um and i didn't show it yet and i want
to
okay so if i go to a very simple like
front-end back end
when i was talking about liveliness and
stuff there's also this the thing where
you can tell it how many replicas of
something you want
so that's a doc or a kubernetes thing so
if i say replicas
i will say three
yeah
hope i got this right
so now we'll say tommy
let's see got that right
what's kind of fun to play with here is
it'll actually say okay you told me you
want three replicas
so again this is something i did in a
very simple front-end back-end
application i just said three replicas
it's it's going and it's creating
multiple instance up instances of that
so now i can say okay let's go to
and then where's my backhand i'm trying
to find my dashboard because that's the
most fun place
because what you can do actually is then
you can go through and you can kill
those processes and watch them restart
up
so i think
there's a front-end backhand front-end
back-end there's so many of them because
it's creating all these instances right
so
there's the zip can
yeah
may not have time for that
i'll see real quick if i get a localhost
8 000 i think
there it is
so here see how it has three replicas
so what's kind of fun with that
is if i go in and i say let's find a
back end instance i want to kill so
there's
uh process id
28052 okay
so now let's go in and we'll say
stop
process
8 0 5 2.
and while it's doing that we'll quickly
switch over here and you can actually
see it had a restart right
and so now if i go in and i kill say the
front end
i can watch it as it restarts and again
this is something where i'm playing with
a you know
semi-advanced feature and it's like i
can do this
you know in the first few minutes of
playing so we'll say stop process
and we'll stop the front end
and if we watch we'll see
front end has stopped and restarted so
i think okay
yes code extension yeah there's that
uh we show that we showed all those
things so let me just wrap up we're
pretty close to time here so um what's
new in next
so there's at
0.11.0 release and that's due out quite
soon
and that has um
that has.net 6 integration and it's
actually moving the codebase 2.6 and
then more adapter integration
as for what's next the team still
you know i talked to the team yesterday
and they're figuring out how ty fits
into the overall like microservice
tooling experience
including visual studio vs code etc
so
you know there there are when you go
into the repo you'll see regular commits
the team's still you know building um
some cool stuff here so
like and you know i was talking to the
dev yesterday and he was like yeah this
is what i'm working on here etc so um
you know there there is some cool stuff
if we look at
if you look at the releases and what's
going on so it's it's a 0.11 is kind of
the next thing and and 10 is the latest
one that's out
but
what i will say is
a few few important things think of it
as a developer tool
uh don't think of it as something to
take a dependency in production because
as they're still figuring out the the
strategy on it it is a
it is a you know it's kind of in flux
however
if it's generating if it's helping me
build microservice applications debug
them locally test them locally and it
generates kubernetes files
i don't have a deep dependency on it and
so i think that's kind of
how i feel personally as a developer on
it
so
um
we talked about docker compose that
didn't actually compare some
it fits in with other things so it's
some it's not really opinionated and it
actually can run side by side with
dapper so it will um it will go through
and you know there are some examples in
there
um
so what i recommend for you i do see one
question here and i'm about that time so
i'm just kind of wrap here i recommend
go through these get started documents
they'll take you through a lot of these
scenarios that i just showed you
um and so you can go through and you can
set up all sorts of things distributed
tracing etc and it'll talk you through
building
and deploying locally this is something
you can do in a few hours or even in a
half hour you can get a good start on it
and then here's a thing i very much
strongly recommend is please take the
thai survey because i said that the team
is figuring out what their overall
strategy is and what their you know what
and a lot of that comes down to
what the developers like so if you look
at this and you say this is useful
useful to me but i can't use it because
it doesn't do this or i really need
support for this one thing um then
please let them know because that's now
is a good time that where that could
really help out
that we have some good microservices
resources uh out on the dotted side i
just want to remind you of
yeah so okay a couple of questions when
can we expect ty to be released so i
think i kind of explained
there is not a
firm shipping date of we are going to
have taiwan oh on this date um
they're still figuring it out and some
of the reasons is
they have a neat experience for net
developers and they've looked at it and
they've said well this is really cool
could we
could we work with other languages or
could we work with other things
you know and bring that same sort of
intelligence in so for instance and this
is they have not said this i'm just
randomly picking but what if they
integrated in with npm and read your
package json or whatever right so or had
extensions that worked with some you
know common some other common things so
so yeah they're they're really kind of
figuring out what their overall strategy
is and so i really think of it as it's a
developer tool and i'm going to use it
to you know build
build my applications and you know
develop kubernetes files and kind of go
from there can you test your kubernetes
deploy with
a docker desktop kubernetes cluster
instead of minicube yes you can the um
you can deploy it to any
like
any endpoint any um
kubernetes endpoint um there's there's
uh in fact if i go over into the docs
for this
so if i
if i go to
docs
and and
if you look through the documentation
and then it has some steps about basic
tutorial for deployment
and so these are the ones that they
write up and that and that is one that
they list out kubernetes and docker
desktop
so they they do call out it takes a
bunch of memory so
uh mini cube has been a very nice kind
of lightweight one that's worked well
for me across platform and so that's
been the main one i've used
as your kubernetes service you can use
it but it it actually took a lot more
setup for me than just going through
with mini cube so
and i
am about a time i i am you know i thank
you very much for your time i recommend
again go out to um
dot net thai if you would like to learn
more and um
have a great time in oslo and i hope to
see you in person uh someday soon
thank you